essentially a spec it's an abbreviation
for special purpose acquisition company
it's a shell company which is usually
organized or sponsored by somebody
experienced in
financial deal making in the internet
workings of wall street and
these sponsors pay the underwriting and
legal fees to take these
shell companies public and they raise
hundreds of millions
sometimes billions of dollars in rare
cases but they usually have the right to
buy
shares of the companies at a deep
discount and then the stack
finds a private company that's looking
to go public to merge with so once they
find the company they merge with it and
then
that that whatever startup that is gets
to be traded on public markets
in 2020 there were 248 stack ipos
according to a research group called
stack insider
and they generated you know 83 billion
dollars in
gross proceeds and those numbers have
already been exceeded in 2021 too the
last time i looked there were
over 300 spec ipos already this year
with more than 100 billion dollars
generated
they're really a win-win for both sides
you know the sponsors that
put these blank check companies these
shell companies together
get stakes in the companies at really
deep discounts and usually get a nice
chunk of the companies they merge with
so it's usually an easy win for them
and the founders of the companies that
are going public the these startups that
merge with the specs can skip over a lot
of the red tape and regulatory
requirements that a traditional ipo
would require
so they can usually make a lot of money
too and you know get
more liquid payouts for their investment
in their time and hedge funds usually
make almost
a guaranteed profit when they invest
early on and the only losers a lot of
the time are the retail investors
the everyday investors who get swept up
in the craze with none of those built-in
advantages
and you know they can get left holding
the bag at the end a lot of the time if
the stock goes down
number one on our stacked billionaire's
list is matt ishbia the ceo of united
wholesale mortgage
which is a mortgage lending business
based in michigan it's the second
largest mortgage lender
in america behind rocket mortgage so
ishbi his net worth was 9.7 billion
dollars as of when we published the list
a few weeks ago he's had an interesting
life he walked onto the basketball team
at michigan state
won an action championship there in 2000
after he graduated from there he joined
his dad's small mortgage business
and that business really took off during
the great recession and he bought out
his
dad with his older brother justin and so
that company uwm
went public in january through a merger
with this back sponsored by
private equity billionaire alec gores
and the stock has performed okay since
then
he's the largest shareholder of the
company now so the stakes worth
you know nine billion dollars more than
that chamath
paula happy tia is a prolific sponsor of
specs he's a former executive at
facebook
venture capitalist now very outspoken on
twitter more than a million twitter
followers
you know tweets a lot about bitcoin or
gamestop or whatever the flavor of the
day
is you know he sponsors facts that merge
with startups like virgin galactic
open door clover health to help make him
a billionaire still has a couple
shell companies in the market that are
still looking for companies to acquire
and take public
separately austin russell is just 26
years old the youngest self-made
billionaire in the world
dropped out of stanford in 2012 after
receiving a teal fellowship for a
hundred thousand dollars
to start his company called luminar
technologies which makes laser sensors
for self-driving cars
and that went public in a spec merger in
december
it's worth 2.5 billion dollars now
russell is after taking that public at
just 26 years old
first you know this the story was only
about new billionaires that that
have become billionaires thanks to spax
that debuted on the list
but they really made a lot of existing
billionaires a lot richer in the last
year too you know alec gores who was
a private equity executive he sponsored
a lot of specs including the deal for
matt ishby's united wholesale mortgage
and his net worth was two billion
dollars last year and this year
three billion dollars so that growth is
almost all due to specs that have helped
him
get another billion dollars richer and
since we published the list and
published this story just in the last
few weeks you know stack activity
has really slowed down in april after
almost
you know a year and a half of the steady
flow of you know accelerating deals
because sec issued new guidance that
would classify
these stack warrants which are similar
to options to buy shares as liabilities
instead of equity
so that would force companies to
recalculate their financials and growth
projections
so that's just started in the last few
weeks and it's really put the future of
this
after you know a year and a half on most
of the of
tens of hundreds of stack ipos is really
in question moving forward
[Music]